[Applause] Jake wman sent one back here for Ben
sherro ahead for Pon and it goes for Co John
Carelli gets knocked down the forward did taken
here by Raymond stop scored what a beautiful play
Locas Raymond gets set for Sweden and finally for
the first time in eight games the Red Wings have
scored the first [Applause] goal pretty darn good
move by Raymond here everybody thinks he's going
all the way around including Martin he stops up
and he reached back in front and tucked it in
he made it look awfully Easy by the time Martin
realized what he was doing he'd already drawn his
right leg away from the goal post and uh that
was theend back for fiser who scored his first
goal as a Redwing Thursday voleno gets stopped so
voleno out with fiser and fabri and Martin that
came in on him fiser again in front for fabry
scores two nothing braby [Music] [Applause]
Fab boy oh boy the excitement
of fish that's his third point
in three game with the flat paddle of the goal
stick Big Time rebound fiser feeds
it out nobody taking care of number
14 and Columbus uh is on their heels Big
Time 45 seconds apart for the first two
goals but they can't sit back that's
for sure right Nick you got to wait this
team was scoring early the Red Wings
have to keep the pedal well this is a
here they come to try oh good play it's
knocked away from strong strong who was
in but Danforth got him and now break the
other way for texier he scores just like
that and that's the uh the bottom forwards
of the Columbus team that reciprocates and
up to that point there had not been a shot
on goal Willie H so that's the other end
of the ice right after the chance strong
is uh looking for a penalty call against
Columbus you see his body language right
there nothing coming and next thing you
know they're going the other
way in behind the Detroit
defense fer waits feno in front Fisher
finds Walman now cider that one over
his Teck and grab by Demitri baronov bonov
finds marchenko missed rebound scores it's
baronov the big Winger going to the net may
have wrapped in off him and it's 22 well it
turned out to be a three on two who did it
hit [Music] last be way he's acting I mean
he missed a net by 5T out of the air out
of the yeah wow that's pretty pretty good
stuff and for tickets Please visit
detroitredwings.com hockeyfights
cancer here's Carelli scores beats who so
far side 13 straight home games Uso's given
up at least three goals going back to last
season by Carelli to get it by Petri he got
the puck there and Petri is flat footed
carelli's moving gets his own little tip
and beats Uso over the bat it looks like and
under the glove to make it 3-2 nice catch Mi
that's the subtlety of hockey and how greatly
skilled these players are I mean Arin tried to
Center goes back for to Brink gets the puck
back into Lin back for to Brink it again Pon
wants it he's got it up front good pass save PE
stepped in front of him lkin hustling in to pick
it up two captains came together Andrew Pete
cleared at this side scores well the break it
finally a nothing play until it ends the back
of the net and when they saw them throw the
puck away there's Raymond to make the for
check but nobody for Columbus is there and
Petri bang bang play I don't know if
this one off the defenseman or not but
top Corner been eight games for du Bret that's
the release he's looking for and we got a tie
game rad Wings had a two nothing lead early
less than four and a half in Columbus tied it
at two after one at the goahead goahead goal
here in the second and Alex to Brink it with
his 10th and his first and eight oh boy has
tied it up sprung scores Daniel sprung hits
for to [Applause] [Music] three there's the
pass it went off the feet of the Columbus
play and strong absolutely threaded the needle
short side right under the [Music] glove you
think he was trying to go up to the top
under the bar certainly came back to use
like kubal and a save made there by whoo on
a close in chance for cylinder that's loose
in front of the goal what a save there Wow it
looked like Ros leik was reaching yeah he was
he was backing up and reaching
so he couldn't get the puck
up that's for sure they didn't
have very good luck at all fired
in by Hall heleno moves up played by
marchenko inadvertently to fiser point
shot W right back in front his car
a Ricochet and it's [Applause] five3
that keep cl to the goal Kender and then this
one boy boy talk about weird and funny bounces
wow this is you know what this is almost a
replay of the goal that Columbus scored I
think the second goal that lion missed the net
by two or three feet it came out to the other
side and fanelly banged it in off the middle of
the air same way from the other side of the ice
a couple of strange ones here today but most
importantly for Detroit a two-goal lead here
early in the third period I think it's going
to be Walman unless already over there when
fiser touched it did fabri get a piece of
it he's pointing to Walman back for gos to
spare the brink it as wman sets up behind
and bear great here's Walman another nice
play there by Christian Fisher had himself
afterno here's Gad played it back but C in
front of fentii penalty over faab out of the box
but line a holds it in he's got some room scores
what a shot gu goal number 200 in the career
of Patrick l top shelf just returning to the
lineup his first in 10 games and a milestone
Mark for Patrick linet good view of the
goenda he could get a all the way out but
there was Lon just inside the line at the
far end and my oh my look at him release that
shot pull and snap just next to cop and right
into the top corner and a we got a one shot
game 8 seconds left that gets blocked lking
on it wants to hold it along the board one last
shot that throwes wide Red Wings win it 5 to four